salut les enfants comme vous le savez je
suis l'un des producteurs de votre film
good boy et malheureusement vous ne
pouvez pas regarder la bande annonce de
votre propre fille et moi il ya de la
drogue de la violence des gros mots et
les mêmes s'il a été décidé que vous
aviez le droit de faire toutes ces
choses dans le film vous n'êtes pas
autorisé à vous voir faire ces choses
dans la bande annonce bien venue à
hollywood j'ai trouvé toutes les armes
dans l'armoire de mes bons perles
annales en japonais ça veut dire
beaucoup
j'ai prévu une petite offre demain
samedi spam net aurait eu qu'à ceux
meilleurs potes on fait tout ensemble
ils sont trop gênant si tu sais pas
embrasser tu te tapes ras la honte chez
aurel on a quelqu'un de ma voisine c'est
une vraie nymphomane voilà ce qui se
passe quand respecte a pas les femmes je
respecte les femmes ma maman et ma
meilleure amie
c'est pas moi mon père va me tuer en
tête avec s'attendre au nom voit le
récupérer vous avez piqué mon sac
restant vous êtes merde il ya de la
drogue dans son sac
vous avez importé de la drogue sur une
aire de jeu
voilà le plan je veux aller à la fête
avec une bière pour que tout le monde
sache que je suis un mec cool tu as quoi
dans ton pantalon montre ce que tu as
j'ai aussi une énorme
je ne donnerai pas la drogue je vais
bien tout droit au nom des français
viendront à nous battre avec des
t-shirts donc fermer un boni ses marges
et d'épiceries avec un truc que je
soupçonne le même taux trop bas qu'on
voit des régions sont brassées
combien de maris elles assez d'hommes
[Musique]